first one you can see it's X plus seven
equals twelve and if you're learning
about equations you know that the left
side and the right side have to be
equivalent they have to be the same they
have to be equal so whatever you do to
the one side of the equation you want to
do the same thing to the other side you
can think of this as like an imaginary
dividing line okay
separating the left on the right sides
we want to get our variable by itself
okay that's our mystery number that's
our unknown and to do that
we have to get rid of the seven now
whenever you want to get rid of
something you want to do the opposite so
if you're adding you want to subtract if
you're subtracting you want to add if
you multiply you divide if you divide
you multiply and so on so for this
problem you can see we're adding seven
plus seven is like adding seven we're
gonna subtract seven from both sides of
the equation to keep it balanced I like
to show the work as I do these problems
and I like to draw a line and then just
go ahead and add straight down so this
will give us X this is going to give us
zero you don't have to write zero that's
nothing and then this equals 12 plus a
negative seven which is five and that's
it we've got it if you want to check
your work with these one-step equations
or any equation for that matter go ahead
and take that quantity put it back into
the original equation and you can see
five plus seven equals twelve now in the
beginning it's easy just to guess what
these values are but we're going through
the steps we're learning because as we
get into the multi-step equations it's
going to be harder to guess what those
answers are so let's go into another
example here we have Y divided by three
so when you see that fraction bar that's
just like division that's like divided
by so Y is divided by three and that
equals negative four so what's the
opposite of dividing multiplying so what
we're going to do is we're going to
multiply both sides by three okay
times three and you can see those threes
are going to cancel because multiplying
and division are opposites they cancel
one another out and so now you can see
you have y equals negative twelve and
that's it if you want to check your work
you can put negative twelve back in
negative 12 divided by 3 is a negative
four okay next example we have 2 times y
now they're right next to each other
okay without anything in between so we
know that they're multiplying together
we want to get the Y by itself so we say
hmm what's the opposite of multiplying
by 2
dividing by two whatever we do to the
left we want to do to the right to keep
it balanced like a teeter totter right
these are going to cancel out and we get
y equals nine okay let's go over here an
example number four here we have D minus
seven equals negative five
okay so minus seven is like subtracting
seven ok the opposite of subtracting
seven is to add seven again we want to
do it to both sides so the negative
seven and seven cancel we get D equals
two now I just want to make a point
right here at this point sometimes
students get a little bit confused they
see the negative 5 and the seven and
they're used to seeing them horizontally
instead of vertically like this so what
I recommend if you get a little bit
confused by this is just to go ahead off
to the side of your paper and just write
negative five plus seven okay and then
you can analyze it from there just a
different perspective okay this one here
now we're getting into two-step
equations okay so these next three
examples two-step equations what you
want to think about doing when you do
two-step equations is you want to get
the numbers on one side you want to get
the variables or the letters on the
opposite side so you're trying to
separate them so here we have 2x and
negative 5 I'm going to get the numbers
on the right side of the equation okay
so you can think of that dividing line
to get rid of this negative 5 I'm going
to do the opposite of subtracting 5 I'm
going to add 5 to both sides so that
gives us 2x equals 20 now we always want
to solve for just one of the variable so
the opposite of multiplying by 2 because
these are right next to each other that
means that they're multiplied together
is to do the opposite divide both sides
by 2 you can see those are going to
cancel one another out two divided by
two is one so we get one x equals 10 now
if you go ahead and put the 10 back in 2
times 10 is 20 minus 5 is 15 so we know
we got the right solution okay now this
one here same idea we want to get the
variables on one side the numbers on the
opposite side so to get rid of this
negative 3 here on the left I'm going to
do the opposite I'm going to add 3 to
both sides X divided by 2 these cancel
out that's 0
negative nine plus three is negative six
again just like this problem over here
you can write it off to the side if
you're just seeing it in that horizontal
orientation or you can go ahead and add
straight down just remember when you see
a minus and a negative those are
interchangeable when you see a plus or a
positive those are interchangeable so
we're just adding a negative nine and a
positive three and we get negative six
now again when you see that fraction bar
that means divided by so the opposite of
dividing by 2 would be to multiply by 2
so I'm going to multiply the left and
the right sides of the equation by 2
these are gonna cancel one another out
because they're opposites and we get
negative 6 times 2 is negative 12 again
just some little pointers here you can
see I'm showing each step as I go along
and I'm trying to keep my equal signs
lined up to separate my left side of my
equation for my right side okay so
you're with me so far
ok last example I'm gonna have a video
on multi-step equations you can check
that out after this video I'll have a
link to that but this last example we're
just going to solve for X we want to get
the numbers on one side variables on the
other we're trying to separate them so
I'm going to subtract 2 okay from both
sides of the equation so we get negative
x equals 6 now when you see this
negative X this is really like a
negative 1 times X so what's the
opposite of multiplying by negative 1
dividing by negative 1 so we're gonna
divide both sides by negative 1 those
are gonna cancel one another out and we
get positive 6 divided by negative 1 is
a negative 6 and you've got it so I hope
you're enjoying these videos subscribe
to the channel check out some of my past
videos give me a thumbs up and a like on
this video if it helped you and I look
forward to seeing you in the next video
I'll talk to you soon